مساء الخير واهلا وسهلا فيكم بحلقه جديده
من برنامجكم بعد الصافره معي انا عبيده
[موسيقى]
لماذا تختار الانديه السعوديه التعاقد مع
لاعبين من تشيلسي شوف بادئ لازم تعرف وضع
تشيلسي المالي تشيلسي بموسم
2021-2022 سجل خسائر بقيمه 154 مليون
دولار امريكي تشيلسي منذ استحواذ كلير ليك
عليه اللي هي برئاسه اقبالي وتوتبولي
السنه الماضيه صرف على التعاقد مع
اللاعبين اكثر من 650 مليون دولار امريكي
تشيلسي ايضا هذا الموسم ما باع الا لاعبين
بقيمه بقيمه اجماليه 74 مليون دولار
امريكي هاي الارقام كلياتها بتبين حجم
المشكله اللي موجوده عند نادي تشيلسي لذلك
تشيلسي بحاجه يتخلص من هؤلاء اللاعبين او
يتخلص من عدد كبير من لاعبي اللي صاروا
زياده على الفريق وصاروا تشيلسي حاليا
عنده تقريبا 31 لاعب بدون انجولو كانت
انتقل على الاتحاد السعودي هذا غير
اللاعبين المع لامديه اخرى يعني مع
اللاعبين المعارين ممكن نحكي بالاربعين
وطالع فبالنسبه لتشلسي له مصلحه انه يبيع
هؤلاء اللاعبين اولا لاسباب ماليه مثل ما
حكينا انه الامور الماليه تبع النادي
مخربطه والسبب الثاني انه صار في مدرب
جديد اسمه هذا المدرب بدو يبني مشروع جديد
مع لاعبين ما شكله عليه عبء وما يفرضوا
عليه ضغط داخل غرف تبديل الملابس وعلى دقه
البدلاء عندي السعوديه الان خلصت مع كانت
اللي هو الاتحاد خلص ما نقولو كانتي هناك
انباء عن قرب انتقال كريدو كوليبالي الى
الهلال هناك انباء عن قرب انتقال حكيم
زياش الى النصر هناك اهتمام على ما يبدو
من جانب الاهلي بادوار مندي هناك اهتمام
ايضا بهوتسون اودوي هناك اهتمام بروميل
لوكاكو من جانب الهلال وبالتالي الانديه
السعوديه شايفه انه تشيلسي وجهها جيده جدا
للتسوق اولا اللاعبين راح يجوا برواتب او
معدل رواتب اقل مثلا من رونالدو بنزيما
ونجوم الميجا ستار اللي عم نحكي كانت
بريال مدريد او ببرشلونه او بالانديه هاي
اللي يعني بتبيع الميجا ستارز تبعها ثانيا
انه اللاعبين نفسهم حابين يطلعوا من
تشيلسي بسبب تخبط اللي عايش الفريق وبسب
الموسم الكارثه اللي قدم من فريق الموصل
الماضي وبسبب عدد الدقائق اللعب وكل واحد
منهم صار يبحث عن فرصه جديده وعمليا اذا
رح نتطلع على انديه اوروبا المهتمه
بالتعاقد مع هؤلاء اللاعبين فراح يكون
عندها مشكله من اثنين اولا يا اما مش
قادره تدفع المبالغ اللي اللاعبين
طالبينها طبعا على صعيد الرواتب يا اما
راح تكون لا تلبي طموحات هؤلاء اللاعبين
اللي اساسا هن نجوب ولكن الموسم الماضي
نزل مستواهم بسبب التخبطات والقارات
الاداريه الخاطئه وتغيير المدربين المستمر
والظروف اللي بيعرفها الكل عن تشيلسي
الموسم الماضي فلندي السعوديه وجدت
بتشيلسي ظلتها المعروف جدا مثل ما قلنا
انه هؤلاء اللاعبين الموجودين مع تشيلسي
هم سوبر ستارز وبالتالي على الصعيد
التسويقي وعلى الصعيد الكروي هن قيمه
كبيره لل سعودي وراح يضيفه كثير وانا
شخصيا اؤيد فكره انه الدول غير المتقدمه
لكره القدم تتعاقد مع لاعبين كبار ان
كانوا ميجا ستارز او سوبر ستارز او حتى
ستارز باوروبا لحتى تبلش تلفت النظر قبل
ما تهتم باكاديمياتها لانه هؤلاء اللاعبين
وجودهم معك بالدوري السعودي او بالدوري
الامريكي او بالدوريات هذه مش كثير كبيره
حول العالم بيعطيك زخم بيعطيك التنشن
وبنفس الوقت باثر بشكل ايجابي على لاعبيك
المحليين اللي راح يحتكوا بهؤلاء اللاعبين
كان بالتدريبات ولا بالملعب وبالتالي رح
يتعلموا منهم كيف تاكل كيف تنام كيف تتمرن
وهذا الامور كلياتها بتاثر بشكل كبير على
اداء اللاعب داخل ارضيه الملعب وعلى
بونيتو الجسديه اما البنيه النفسيه فايضا
باثر فيها هذا الموضوع لانه موجود لاعبين
كبار جايبين دوري الابطال ولاعبين
المنافسات كبيره بيخلوا اللاعب السعودي او
الامريكي او الصيني او الهندي يكون دائما
نتعلم كيف يتعامل مع الضغوطات كيف يفكر
بعقليه اللاعب المحترف الكبير وهذا امر
يعود طبعا بالايجاب على الرياضه في هذه
الدوله الان كان في حديث بالاوساط
الانجليزيه وبالصحف الانجليزيه عن موضوع
العلاقه ما بين صندوق الاستثمارات السعودي
وشركه كلير ليك اللي مثل ما حكينا ماسكه
60% من نادي تشيلسي هاي العلاقه حسب الصحف
الانجليزيه انه في تبادلات تجاريه
وتعاملات تجاريه وذهب البعض الى حد القول
انه الانديه السعوديه اختارت تشيلسي لحتى
تفيد هاي الشركه وبسبب مصالح بعيده عن كره
القدم ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه لا يوجد اي
دليل على هذا الكلام لا يوجد اي
شيء ملموس حول تداخل ما بين المصالح
التجاريه لصندوق الاستثمارات مع كلير لايك
او مع توت بويلي اللي هو ايضا شريك كلير
ليك تشيلسي ولا يوجد اي كلام عن موضوع
تاثير هذه العلاقات على
الانديه المسيطر عليها صندوق الاستمارات
او المستحوذ عليها صندوق الاستثمارات
السعودي بالوقت الراعي وبما انه ما عنا
دليل على هذا الكلام تبع الصحف الانجليزيه
ففينا نذهب لنظريه انه الانديه السعوديه
شافت في سوق جيد عده تشيلسي في لاعبين
جيدين قادرين يخدموا مصالحها وبالتالي في
عنا شره جاهز انه يشتري ويدفع مبالغ وفي
طرف اخر جاهز انه يبيع لعيبته وما عنده اي
مشكله وعلى قلبه مثل العسل وبالتالي موضوع
الذهاب الى حد انه نحكي عن موضوع الامور
التجاريه
والتعاملات التجاريه وتاثيرها على الصفقات
هذا امر لحد الان ما عنا عليه اي دليل او
مش قادرين نوصل له قد يكون صحيح قد لا
يكون ولكن لحد الان ما عليه اي ادله
بالنهايه المستفيد الاكبر من هاي الصفقات
كلياتها بالتاكيد هن الطرفين معهم مش بس
السعوديه ولا بس تشيلسي تشيلسي مستفيده عم
يحقق مصالحه والسعوديه ايضا عم تحقق
مصالحها من خلال دعم
فكره جلب اللاعبين الكبار لتطوير مستوى
الدوري السعودي وللترويج للكره السعوديه
ولتحضير لكاس العالم 20/3 هذا كان كل شيء
بحلقه لون بعض الصافي حتى ننتقل الاسبوع
المقبل